tout s'habiller pareil à la rentrée
prochaine ce n'est pas au programme pour
l'instant le gouvernement veut mener des
expérimentations dans plusieurs
territoires en primaire collège et même
lycée devant cet établissement lillois
il y a ceux qui sont contre l'uniforme
parce que du coup
on peut pas se permettre d'être soi-même
le tissu va être plus ou moins luxueux
donc les familles riches
[Rires]
beaucoup plus beau les chaussures la
différence va se faire par les choses
sur les cartables et fournitures donc
l'uniforme crée
l'inégalités
toujours plus je vais demander un habit
que tu as sur toi
on a dit qu'on prenait son temps
donne-moi ton pantalon monsieur je
récupère demain tu veux partir en
pantalon
tenez vous droit la tenue
on est en uniforme c'est bien costume de
plats
pour le 2 s'il vous plaît bon et ben
écoutez retourne à votre place pour le
moment vous êtes bien
comment méfiez-vous des petits jeunes
mais c'est la vie
[Musique]
tu préfères quoi Julien qu'est-ce qui te
met plus à l'aise oh bah il a l'air très
à l'aise là
[Musique]
le chef de l'État et le gouvernement
changerait à une tenue unique comme
Emmanuel Macron l'a expliqué hier dans
cette interview un média prise et des
jeunes sans avoir un uniforme on peut
dire vous vous mettez en jean t-shirt et
veste la question de la tenue unique qui
n'est pas l'uniforme qui à mon avis est
plus acceptable peut paraître un peu
moins stricte d'un point de vue
disciplinaire je vais me référer à une
expérience que des millions d'entre nous
en fait jouer au football portez le même
maillot ça crée pas un sentiment
ça crée pas un sentiment de solidarité
dans une école
pas n'importe quoi tout le monde sait
que ça crée un sentiment de solidarité
de porter le même maillot et c'est la
même chose dans les écoles solutions
on est parti en caleçon je t'adore non
c'est vrai
quelle conjugaison est correcte
que je salue
ou que tu reçu
[Applaudissements]
allez-y
que tu ressusces et c'est une bonne
réponse
[Applaudissements]
une petite bête
et elle ne boude pas leur plaisir j'en
peux plus parler palpée
donnez-moi quelque chose un lien sur des
paquets de gâteaux pas de patrouille
vendu chez Lidl renvoyait au fait vers
un site porno véritable scandale puisque
jusqu'ici le seul biscuit qui menait les
enfants vers du porno c'était une hostie
allez
vu le film Barbie et c'est vrai que
et je le déplore encore une fois j'étais
influencé par ce film par toutes ces
influences qui font la promotion de
cette chirurgie
malheureusement et
du coup j'ai fait une retouche il y a
quelques jours pourquoi
parce que j'étais influencée alors déjà
première chose ne croyez pas les
influenceurs arrêtez d'acheter les
produits qui dont ils font la publicité
parce que ça c'est toujours une
catastrophe mais comment on fait on peut
renforcer la sécurité de Marie Porto
sur les réseaux c'est pas beau vous
allez voir des problèmes mais je vais
pas avoir de problème je dis simplement
ce que vous dites c'est-à-dire que ce
sont des produits qui sont quand même
assez dangereux parfois pour la santé
faites attention à vous tes cheveux
c'est les vrais cheveux
c'est une perruque
comme
[Rires]
question est-ce que les hommes le font
parce que moi j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
un bon coup donc j'ai eu peur
à 20h48
c'est que c'est une catastrophe pendant
longtemps après le 10 février dernier
date de l'accident provoqué par Pierre
Palmade vous vous êtes pas exprimé vous
répondez aux questions des journalistes
à l'occasion de la promotion de la pièce
à venir avec Pierre mais ce silence il
disait quoi je vais vous répondre ce que
j'ai répondu répondu aux autres
il y a tout ce que les gens ont entendu
et vu et puis à ce que je sais ce que
j'ai vu ce que j'ai entendu et qui n'est
pas du tout en la faveur de Pierre
Palmade et c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi
de me taire je pense que si vous aimez
quelqu'un surtout l'amitié
vous allez jusqu'au bout parce qu'il y
aurait tellement de raisons dans la vie
de suivre le vent de toujours suivre le
courant de renier ce qu'on a aimé et au
fond moi j'ai presque à la fin de ma vie
et je me dis alors quoi j'aurais été
quelqu'un d'obéissant je me serais trahi
moi-même et pourquoi au point de
considérer aujourd'hui que c'est plus
votre ami je ne suis plus son ami c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose et quand
tu as
tu as je suis toujours posé la question
aussi pierre Palma de tout mon ami j'ai
je crois que j'ai aimé pour deux je me
réveille de ça c'est douloureux mais
mais moi je peux me regarder dans la
glace bonjour c'est Sandrine merci
évidemment sur la prestation d'Isabelle
ils turbury d'avoir une question elle
était meilleure que toi ou pas
je vais te la retourner est-ce qu'elle
est meilleur que toi Ashley sur le 12 15
de BFM
maintenant il y a une
c'est dégueulasse mais vous savez moi il
y a des manèges qui font flipper donc du
coup des fois je serre le cul
[Musique]
on termine avec la grande muraille qui a
survécu aux guerres et à l'érosion mais
il a suffi d'un tractopelle et d'un peu
de bêtises à deux Chinois pour réaliser
ce trou regardez dans l'édifice
emblématique de la Chine érigée à partir
du troisième siècle avant notre ère
pourquoi ce trou et bien selon la
télépubique Chinoise ils ont admis
pendant leur interrogatoire qui voulait
créer un raccourci tout simplement on a
qu'une vie
[Musique]
on a qu'une vie c'est comme ça que ça se
passe bien